[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: So Su, you've
been a Googler for five years.
SU FU: Mhm, yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Working
as a software engineer.
SU FU: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Can
you tell us all about it?
SU FU: Sure.
I joined Google
about five years ago.
So I started from Android.
I'd been working on
Android Hangouts, and then
Android Messages.
And it's been very
challenging and rewarding,
since there are
hundreds of millions
of people can use the
feature that you're building.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Android
Hangouts and Messages, wow!
So you've really been hitting
lots and lots of users.
SU FU: I hope so.
Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
And then from that,
now you've moved
on to services infrastructure?
Could you tell us a
little bit about that?
SU FU: Yes.
So I joined the service
infrastructure team
about a year ago.
It's been exciting,
and quite challenging
as well, since it's unlike
Android applications.
Service infrastructure
is a little more hidden,
that the end customers--
service producers may
not even meet them,
or interact with them.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So what exactly
is services infrastructure?
If I am, like, a developer,
how do I interface with it,
or how do I use it?
Or--
SU FU: Sure.
Yes.
So service infrastructure is
Google's foundational service
platform that Google uses
to build our own APIs
and services.
Now, as an external
service producer,
you can utilize our Google
service infrastructure
to manage your own APIs and
also publish your services.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
So if I'm a developer
and I'm building
some kind of application, and
I want to use Google services,
there's so many
good ones, right?
How would I go about getting
started using them on service
infrastructure platform?
SU FU: Yes.
So you can use
service infrastructure
through cloud endpoints.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SU FU: So basically you can--
so cloud endpoint is the
API management platform
in that shell.
And then you can--
it can help you create,
deploy, monitor,
protect your APIs and services.
All you have to do
is-- you can write
your API and your services in
any language or any framework,
but you need to also write a
service configuration, which
may have a service name, title,
RPC API definitions, and also
how your service may behave.
For example, for each user,
what is the quota limit for it?
Or what kind of
API metrics do you
want to gather for your APIs?
And then you just push
that service configuration
to the service infrastructure,
and we do all the work for you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
SU FU: So during
runtime, your service
may have API calls to the
service infrastructure
for pre-condition checks.
For example, whether this
user calling your service
has enough quota limits
to call the service.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, nice.
SU FU: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
And then the details
of creating all this
are in the documentation,
and we'll put a link
to that in the comments below.
But also, isn't it-- like, if I
want to consume existing Google
services-- like maybe
translation, or Maps,
or something like that--
that's all run by the services
infrastructure team, too.
SU FU: Yes.
So basically the
service infrastructure
is used for almost all Google
internal services and APIs.
So all these-- like Maps
APIs, or translation APIs--
are built--
I mean, are managed
and published
using our service
infrastructure, which
is also One Platform, the
T-shirt that I'm wearing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
Yes, nice green T-shirt.
I thought it was Android, but
now I see it's One Platform.
[CHUCKLING] Good thing we're
not filming on a green screen
today.
So that's one of the
things that I thought
was really neat about
this, was that the things
that we do for managing,
scalability, and quota, and all
of that for our
services are also
available for your
services as a developer.
SU FU: Yeah.
Exactly.
Like monitoring, logging,
authentication, billing,
and quota management.
All those things is
what we're providing
to the service producers.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
what's it like, day to day,
being a software
engineer on all of this?
SU FU: I mean--
so for this new project--
or I mean, for the
service infrastructure,
so that end users will see
the end-to-end experience.
It's awesome.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
And now, outside of doing
software engineering,
you also have a 20% project
working with the TensorFlow
team, right?
SU FU: Yes.
Thank you, Laurence, for
presenting this experience
to me and opportunity to me,
to work on this new YouTube
channel, Coding TensorFlow.
Yes.
So I'm very passionate
about AI, and also Google
has this amazing AI platform,
TensorFlow framework, for--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I've heard of it.
I have.
SU FU: Yes.
So that everyone can--
I mean, everyone can use AI
and use their imagination
and build their own things,
and their own applications.
And I really want to promote
this in the Chinese market.
China has a big
market in AI as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
mean, with AI becoming
such an emergent thing,
not just as a technology,
but also as a new tool
for software developers,
and with so many software
developers in China,
that it's really nice to be
able to reach out to them.
And what's your
experience been like?
Have you had feedback
from developers who
have been watching your videos?
SU FU: Yeah.
They're surprised because I am
a "software engineer" at Google,
but I also do this advocate
thing for TensorFlow.
I think the interesting
idea is, Google really
provides this culture that
allows me to do anything
that can excite me.
So working as a full-time
engineer in the service
infrastructure team, also
promoting AI for developers.
So it's been very rewarding.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And that's great.
And your first batch of videos
were around TensorFlow Lite.
So TensorFlow working on
Android and iOS phones.
And what's your next
set going to be?
SU FU: Yeah, it's
going to be Javascript.
LAURENCE MORONEY: JavaScript?
So TensorFlow in the browser?
SU FU: Yeah, exactly that.
You can build your
AI models and run it
in a browser using
JavaScript, or Node.js.
So it's pretty neat.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
SU FU: It's pretty light.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice pun.
So thank you so much.
One final question, though,
would be if-- for developers,
if they want to learn
more about what you're
doing with
TensorFlow, or if they
want to learn more about
services infrastructure,
where would you point them?
Or what advice
would you give them?
SU FU: Yes.
So, for service
infrastructure, we
have pretty concise
documentation.
We can paste a link
in the YouTube videos.
And also, for the
TensorFlow Lite,
we do, and the
JavaScript, we do--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Coming soon.
SU FU: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
And, like, they're
available-- the Chinese ones
for the Chinese audience are
on our WeChat channel, right?
SU FU: Yes.
WeChat, and-- since
WeChat is so popular,
everyone is on it,
including TensorFlow.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Even I'm on it.
SU FU: Yeah, even you're on it.
And thanks for the Chinese
advocates at Google.
They provide this WeChat
post depicting the TensorFlow
Lite, and also the videos.
And as is in WeChat, we
also posted the videos
on Bilibili, which is a video
sharing platform for comics
and animation.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, really?
SU FU: Yes, but it's
been very popular.
A lot of people are watching
them for development.
It's surprising.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh.
I'll have to check that one out.
I hadn't seen that.
Comics and animation are
two of my favorite things,
and now we've got
TensorFlow there, too.
Thank you so much, Su.
And thanks, everybody, for
watching this episode of Coffee
with a Googler.
If you have any
questions for me,
or if you have any
questions for Su,
just please leave them
in the comments below.
And whatever you
do, don't forget
to hit that subscribe button.
Thank you.
SU FU: Subscribe button.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Subscribe button.
Well done.
SU FU: Thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]